welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in DC films once again I have a
future one finally shared with us by
James Gunn and every Fanboy who prefers
his DC movies in high contrast iMacs
four hours long is cocked in his arms
Henry Cavill style because some folks
got a big day of hot take typing ahead
of them big announcements like a
Superman Legacy film coming July 2025 a
new DCU Batman with Damian Wayne Robin
and a brave in the Bold film but also a
Robert Pattinson Batman sequel then a
Lantern's Green Lantern True Detective
HBO series and then more series like
Waller Booster Gold Paradise Lost and
more films like a wild Storm movie The
Authority Supergirl Swamp Thing This is
the biggest update in DC movies that
we've gotten in years and I for one am
relieved to see some plan albeit one
that I think we're all gonna have to
give some benefit of the doubt to and I
think James Gunn gets that I'm gonna
break down everything we learned and
what it means for the future of comic
book media my general thoughts on this
plan and what parts of it I'm a little
worried about and a reminder to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive launching February 17th where I
will be going deeper into analyzing
films not just marvel stuff I'm going to
look at all films of the more
investigatory Focus kind of the classic
new Rockstar stuff but like more
obsessed I really think you're gonna
love it okay so James Gunn released a
video that went through his entire plan
he also did like a meeting with the
Press yesterday he said that he and
Peter's goal is to connect everything
that in the past all the DC titles were
kind of interconnected and fans didn't
really understand how things connected
to each other and what narrative
implications to really take seriously so
going forward they're gonna have a very
clear DC Universe but also titles
outside of that universe that they're
going to firmly establish as DC else
worlds DC else worlds will include the
Matt Reeves Batman films and the Todd
Phillips Joker films this year 2023 the
four planned DC movies will still come
out Shazam Fury the Gods coming March
17th The Flash is still coming June 16th
Blue Beetle is coming August 18th and
Aquaman in Lost Kingdom is coming
December 25th now other playing DC
titles include Joker falia Duke coming
October 4th 2024 reminder this is going
to be a follow-up to the Joaquin Phoenix
Joker film this one's gonna be
co-starring Lady Gaga as Harley Quinn
and it's been described as a musical
we've also seen some early images for it
I don't know what this movie's gonna be
but I'm very excited for it we've also
confirmed to get a sequel to the
red Matt Reeves the Batman they're gonna
get at least one more of these movies
and it's gonna be released on October
3rd 2025 currently titled the Batman
part two okay so the new slate of James
Gunn and Peter saffron's vision for the
new DC titles going forward beyond that
they've called it Gods and Monsters and
this is really chapter one or they're
phase one of their plan and James good
said that the following titles are not
the entirety of this chapter one Gods
and Monsters section okay first title
Creature Commandos this is going to be
an animated 7 episode series that James
Gunn has written it's already in
production this is like a team of
classic monsters assembled to fight
Nazis but this is gonna be a modern take
on the concept but the key here is that
James Gunn wants the characters to move
in and out of the animation with the
same actors doing the voices as we'll
see in live action this is similar to
what Marvel's approach has been and what
if okay the next title is an Amanda
Waller show a spin-off of Peacemaker
Viola Davis is returning it's gonna be
written by Crystal Henry who worked on
Watchmen on HBO and Jeremy Carver the
creator of the Doom Patrol TV series and
I think it'll be good to just have a
Waller series that connects a lot of the
threads that we saw in past DC film
films including both Suicide Squad
movies what James Gunn did in Peacemaker
and even recently with Black Adam okay
next is what James Gunn said will be the
true beginning of the DCU Superman
Legacy this is the Superman film that
James Gunn is writing and he may direct
but we don't know that for sure yet
saffron said it's not gonna be an origin
story it will focus on Superman
balancing his Kryptonian Heritage with
his human upbringing how he is the
embodiment of True Justice in the
American way and that he is a kindness
in a world that thinks that kindness is
old-fashioned it will release July 11
2025. they reminded everyone that Henry
Cavill will not return to play the Man
of Steel but they have not announced who
the new Kal-El will be yeah as you can
see the details are pretty light on this
one but they're seeming to touch on
really the classic themes of what people
expect from a Superman story really this
sounds like the story that I wanted Man
of Steel 2 to be because Man of Steel
ended with Clark's first day on the job
at the Daily Planet and the next time we
saw him he was going to war with Bruce
Wayne we never really got that act to
good stuff about Superman so I'm excited
to live with the day to Danish of what
callow goes through but I'll admit I
will really miss Henry Cavill in this
role I'm excited to see who they cast
though okay next big announcement
lanterns this will be an HBO series in
which gun and saffron have described as
a True Detective style series calling it
terrestrial based it's going to feature
a team up between Hal Jordan and Jon
Stewart and gun said it's gonna bring in
other lanterns who watch over Earth as
kind of their Precinct and they discover
quote a terrifying secret that will tie
into the broader narrative that connects
all DC films which makes them wonder
what is the terrifying secret they
discover on Earth we've already seen the
anti-life equation and Zack Snyder's
Justice League but it sounds like it's
something related to that when it comes
to the DC HBO things you really see them
doing other formats that have been
successful in HBO like True Detective
like Game of Thrones and finding DC
versions of that now another movie will
be coming out a fascinating title I'm
really curious to see what they do with
the authority this is gonna be based on
the Wild Storm characters this is a team
of superheroes who go to the extremes to
protect the planet by any means
necessary this is part of the 90s Jim
Lee Run Gun said one of the things that
the DCU is that it's not just a story of
heroes and villains not every film and
TV show is going to be about a good guy
versus bad guy giant things from the sky
comes the good guy wins there are white
hats black hats and gray hats and
Stafford said they are kind of like Jack
Nicholson and A Few Good Men they know
you want them on the wall or at least
they believe that now the image we see
shows the original lineup of the Wild
Storm Authority characters the winged
character is Swift that's a Tibetan
woman who possesses wings and sharp
talents the guy in the tunic and
turtleneck is the doctor a Dutch drug
addict and Shaman who possesses the
combined powers of the hundreds of
shamans who came before him down in the
front the badass there is midnighter
he's a bioengineered Batman Pastiche who
possess the ability to foresee his
opponent's moves in combat very cool guy
contrastingly the solar fella up above
him is Apollo a bioengineered Superman
Pastiche the Union Jack lady up front is
Jenny Sparks a British woman who could
generate and turn into electricity to
the right of her is the engineer a
scientist who had replaced her blood
with nine pints of nanotechnology and
can recreate solid objects with it and
then up above her is Jack hawksmore who
psychically bonds to cities to
communicate with them and receive powers
from them yeah it's a really really
weird lineup I see why James Gunn
considers this passion project I would
say expect something like the misfit
toys of The Suicide Squad with some of
the social commentary of the boys but
there's more of an earnestness to this
group that I'm really excited to see
play out I'm just really surprised
they're doing this as a movie okay
another HBO series Paradise Lost it's
going to be a Game of Thrones style
drama set on the mascara that's Wonder
Woman's birthplace AKA Paradise Island
they promise political Intrigue scheming
between Power Players this is going to
be taking place long before the events
of the Wonder Woman films as someone who
loves drama between Queen vs Queen
princess versus princess from shows like
House of the Dragon rings of power I'm
really excited for this series okay
another huge important movie the
introduction of the DCU Batman the Brave
and the Bold in which Bruce Wayne will
team up with Damian Wayne whom James's
gonna call it a little son of a
this is gonna be from the grant Morrison
run that introduced Batman to a son he
never knew existed and Damian Wayne is a
little murderous tween who's been raised
by assassins it's gonna be a strange
father-son story this is going to be the
beginning of the bat family in the DC
Universe and a reminder this will not be
Robert Pattinson it's gonna be a new
Batman whom they have not announced yet
but having a Batman and Robin story in
the DCU I think will be a good contrast
to the Robert Pattinson loner Batman
that we see in the Matt Reeves side of
the universe in the else worlds okay
another HBO Max Series Booster Gold
Booster Gold is hilarious he's one of
the lower tiered losers from the 80s
he's a loser from the future who uses
technology for the future that's basic
at that time to come back to today and
to pretend to be a superhero he's got
major imposter syndrome he's a
fascinating character and I hope they
get Anthony start a plan okay another
film Supergirl woman of Tomorrow James
Gunn said it's gonna be based on the Tom
King written miniseries a very different
take than what most would think of with
the character really they're going to
highlight the contrast between Superman
who was sent to Earth raised by loving
parents in Kansas but Supergirl was
raised on a rock just a chunk from
Krypton after it exploded had to watch
everyone around her die be killed in
terrible ways for the first 14 years of
her life and then come to Earth what
does that do to a person so again
Supergirl girl woman of tomorrow that's
gonna be a movie also a movie Swamp
Thing a horror film that's gonna close
out the first part of the chapter and
James Gunn is made clear it will be one
of these else World stories which I'm
actually excited by because it'll give
it more bandwidth to be even weirder and
crazy and scary Now reminder the Ezra
Miller Flash movie is still coming and
they acknowledge the drama around Ezra
Miller saffron said Ezra is completely
committed to their recovery we are fully
supportive of that Journey they are on
right now when the time is right when
they are ready to have that discussion
we will all figure out the best path
forward but right now they are
completely focused on their recovery and
in our conversation with them in the
last couple months it feels like they
are making enormous progress okay and
then on the recent Zachary Levi Pfizer
tweet James Gunn said actors filmmakers
that I work with are going to say things
that I agree with and things that I
don't agree with I can't be changing my
plans all the time because an actor says
something that I don't agree with at the
same token if someone is doing something
that is morally reprehensible that's a
different story and we have to take that
into account okay now to all this James
Gunn just acknowledges the DC history
past that really no one was minding the
mint they were giving away IP like they
were party favors at any credit smiled
at them he threw some shade at past
Warner Brothers and DC execs for
mishandling things with Henry Cavill but
his goal is to just give a transparent
plan as he moves forward and make it
clear what stuff connects and what stuff
doesn't and I gotta say I'm optimistic
about this plan I don't know if all
these titles will work I don't know if
any of these titles will get canceled or
not what I like about James Gunn what
I've always liked about James Gunn is
his transparency with the fans this guy
is always on Twitter shooting down
theories when they don't make sense
calling out news sites when they print
crazy headlines that are just factually
wrong he understands at this point that
there's expectation management you have
to do with the fan base to keep them on
board and this is something that not all
other big genre franchise heads know how
to do I like Kevin feige but that guy is
a man behind the curtain so the fact
that James Gunn's willing to come out
here and make some difficult choices
even stuff that he knows huge sections
of the fan base will be really pissed
off at him for I think it's necessary
steps that we have to take of these
titles I think the one I'm most excited
for is lanterns I think a Hal Jordan Jon
Stewart team up is going to be awesome I
think doing the Green Lantern Corps as a
serial detective story rather than
trying to fit in all that mythology in
one movie I think this is definitely the
way to go I think it's still too early
for me to form any opinions about
Superman Legacy or the Brave and the
Bold I feel like I'll have more of an
opinion when they announce directors for
these titles and lead actors to play
these roles but I am glad to know a
Superman movie is back on the schedule
and will focus on the time of Superman's
life that I feel like modern movies
haven't really shown us enough of but I
want to know your thoughts on all this
again I think we should all do our best
to keep an open mind about this and it's
just nice to know that we have a future
again and that future is being crafted
by genuine nerds who have proven
themselves with a good track record of
films and TV hey a reminder to subscribe
to the Deep dive you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]